bueno como el presidente dijo y como han
dicho todos ha sido algo sin precedentes
la corte suprema- nunca había quitado
delitos la corte suprema de los estados
unidos por años ha agregado y ampliado
los derechos civiles de las personas y
está la primera vez que lo quitan lo que
significa que queda la enmienda 14 de
los eeuu que donde está amparada el
derecho al aborto queda vulnerable sobre
sus derechos los derechos al matrimonio
igualitario el derecho al matrimonio
entre personas de diferentes razas
también queda en juego debido a que son
consideradas considerados derechos
estatales y lo que hace esta nueva este
nuevo derecho es lo que acaba de hacer
la corte suprema en simplemente abrir la
puerta a que esos derechos ya
establecidos y ya que la corte ya
decidió que son derechos que están
amparado bajo la constitución queden
abiertos a que se haga lo mismo en
legislaturas estatales que se empiecen
nuevamente a usar leyes en contra de
esos derechos con el plan de llegar a la
corte y que la corte lo derogue porque
ya como él dijo el puesto más
la corte está dispuesta a escuchar
nuevamente esos casos y con lo
extremista
y peligrosa que es esta corte suprema
porque no hay otra forma de describirlo
puede ser que veamos menos derechos y
que más derechos estén en juego en los
próximos años
yoani justamente algo que es necesario
analizar es que ahora cada estado va
aprobar sus leyes ya algunos hablaron de
prohibición ya algunos han hablado de
restricciones e incluso hay una
situación sumamente grave y es que las
mujeres pueden ser perseguidas y
judicial izadas por acceder a este tipo
de práctica por ejemplo en misisipí se
reactiva esto ya lo hacíamos con nuestro
corresponsal y es que se reactiva una
ley de 1952 que castiga a las mujeres
con hasta 10 años de cárcel que se puede
esperar entonces
lo que vamos a esperar es que por eso el
presidente enfatizó de que esto va a ser
un tema que va a estar en las urnas este
año porque porque vamos a ver que en
estados donde gane republicanos donde
vengan con esas mesas ideologías
extremistas y peligrosas van a tratar de
invitar leyes como la de misisipí y van
a tratar de evitar leyes como la de
texas donde también se penaliza a la
mujer y al mismo tiempo hay lo que se
llama un sistema de bounty que es un
tema donde dice que si una persona
denuncia a otra si se hace un aborto o
si provee uno esa persona puede recibir
recompensa entonces estamos hablando de
que si se elige más republicanos si se
eligen candidatos y políticos con
convicciones tan extremistas vamos a ver
que van a empezar a imitar estas leyes
no van a empezar a invitar leyes como la
de texas como la de misisipí como la de
la florida que recientemente también
pasó una ley similar entonces ese es el
miedo que se sigan replicando a través
del país y aunque sí haya estado donde
el aborto va a continuar siendo seguro y
legal y van a abrir sus puertas a otras
personas
esperemos que en estos estados no se
elijan candidatos y políticos que vayan
a poner en juego ese derecho entonces
estamos hablando que es un tema político
es un tema electoral y es importante
enfatizar eso para la comunidad latina
aquí en eeuu donde sabemos que casi el
60% de los latinos aprueba que el
derecho al aborto siga siendo seguro y
legal eso es un tema político es un tema
de elecciones y por eso vamos a
continuar hablando sobre esto como un
tema importante no solo de salud pública
sino también un tema que va a estar en
las urnas el 8 de noviembre